[Music]
what's up Wolfgang there is something
that is very interesting circulating
around right now on the Internet
we were just given the first promo art
for Avengers 4 leaked online just barely
a day ago but it appears that there may
be some leaked concept art for Avengers
4 that is leaked as well before we dive
into the video be sure to hit that
subscribe button to stay up to date on
Avengers 4 so this new concept art is of
vision also a quick spoiler alert if you
have not seen Avengers infinity war yet
so a couple of things here first off
there's two photos both are a vision as
you can see but one is just him in the
single photo and then the other one is
three different pictures in one so let's
talk about the first picture for a
second because it seems like this is the
same picture that they used for the
promo art for a vision in Avengers age
of Ultron there is one main difference
though and that is his eyes in the promo
art for age of Ultron he has normal eyes
but in this photo his eyes are wydad out
now for those of you saying well that
doesn't really matter in this whole
photo all of him is whited out I'll get
to that in a second because it plays a
major importance of what these photos
could show us let's talk about that
second photo first
this photo appears to be brand new the
visions you see in this photo have never
been used before at least not to my
knowledge and what I focus on in this
picture on the left side is the gem
inside his head you can see that there's
a lot of roughness to the right side of
his forehead on there there's some lines
that could be cuts and it's really on
kind of the upper right side of his head
and what I'm thinking is is that if they
bring him back to life in Avengers 4
this is just scar tissue this is just
damaged which brings us to the main
point of what these photos are really
telling us it appears that vision is
going to be brought back in Avengers 4
as the West Coast Avengers version of
him so in the comics vision dies but
then he's later brought back to life and
in the West Coast Avengers storyline he
is portrayed as this white
mostly looking character that you can
see here so these concept photos look an
awful lot like vision does in the West
Coast Avengers now vision also looked
like this in the Infinity Gauntlet
series when the Avengers took on Thanos
now they obviously didn't go with this
all-white version of vision in the MCU
and here's why I personally think they
didn't I think they were waiting for
this particular moment at the end of
Avengers infinity war so they could
bring him back in this all-white form if
you noticed that when Thanos ripped the
mine stone out of his head and vision
died he went limbless of course but the
color went away and sure he did a lot of
work on vision we're not too sure on
what all she did to get the mine stone
out of his head to separate him from the
mine stone but it seemed like she got
pretty far and I bet you that in
Avengers 4 they figured out a way to
bring him back to life and when they do
I don't think the color will come back
to him I think that the mine Stone
perhaps gave him his color and then
we'll get this all-white version a
vision that we've seen in the comics if
you compare these two photos you can
clearly see that these are super similar
to each other again
this version of vision in the comics is
this white ghostly version of him which
is clearly what they're going for in
these concept art photos even with the
white eyes as you can see here in the
comics his eyes are white now obviously
there's a little bit of shade under here
that's the black but if you look at the
people it's white and if you notice the
background of these photos it really
looks like what Conda so that would fall
right into place was Sheree being able
to revive vision so if these are
legitimate concept art photos for
Avengers 4 it appears that they're going
to bring back vision in his all-white
form for Avengers 4 and I think that it
was pretty set up with the way that
Sheree was working on him for them to
bring back vision and Avengers 4 anyways
but what do you guys think you think
that this is setting up the revival of
vision in Avengers 4 or do you think
that this doesn't really mean anything
and they're probably fake and vision is
dead for good until the Avengers somehow
figure out a way to reverse everything
that Thanos did let's discuss let me
know your thoughts in the comments below
and be sure to hit that like button and
subscribe to my channel to stay
today on Avengers 4 thank you so much
for watching woof woof
[Music]